like 40 seconds earlier this time we're
live at least I think hopefully people
getting this getting this maybe yes no
ah whatever I'll talk anyway I'm used to
talking it's just a camera with no
direct feedback it's almost as if that
is a decent chunk of my life okay we got
going on here
hey thank you beat master alright so a
couple of things about tonight before we
get going
first is we got a hard cutoff time of an
hour because I am getting back to
watching more sure I've only gotten
through the first two episodes of the
new season so far I got stuff to do and
two things I had a second thing oh and
then I lost it again because I saw the
question about a hanger okay my
recommendation for a hangover is not
what you do after it's what you do
during between drinks you drink water
because the major part of a hangover is
dehydration so if you drink water
regularly while you are drinking you're
less likely to have a hangover in the
first place
oh I I remember what the other thing was
so last couple times I have really
gotten lost trying to back up two
questions that I know I missed so like
look I'm gonna just stay with the with
the chat as current and if I miss a
question and it rolls out of the chat
ask it again and maybe I'll catch you
next time but the whole trying to scroll
back through has gotten out of hand and
in I'm kind of shrug getting given up on
that so yeah that's how that goes
how are things things are good oh and
tis the season I have egg nog ah our
cutoff time you just jinxed it knowing
me quite possibly but we will see hey
there Cara like the script thank you I
can't remember where I got this scarf
like I remember which scarves
like people made for me and things like
that this wasn't something like that
I don't remember where I got it though I
think I think my mother gave this to me
because she gave me a number of scarves
about a year ago never had a hangover I
youth oh yeah you're not kidding
in light of Disney Plus about to drop
soon oh for god that was about to happen
do you plan on doing any Disney related
videos I mean I don't have a I have a
theme to do I mean I talk about Disney
stuff anyway I'll probably do a review
of frozen to when that comes out I don't
have it officially on the docket because
I don't know when I'm gonna get to it
but I'm pretty sure I'll end up seeing
that there'll be a video on that I know
I talked Disney in general one of these
days I'll give like my I'll give like my
top I'll probably do a top 5 ma-maybe a
top 10 Disney Villains you know stuff
like that there's like stuff like that
has been in the basically in the junk
pile of ideas to do eventually I'm not
sure I'll pull the trigger on it in
honor of Disney Plus um but I mean that
stuff's always there just got back from
a pub with my University's debate
Society so it's a bit late for your
advice ah sorry sorry Bailey you are in
trouble then honestly if you haven't
gone to bed yet you still have time to
drink water so just singing whether or
not you agree with youtubers like
razörfist or Alpha Omega sin huh this
starts out well I don't know who either
those people are they do make a lot of
solid valid points it's certainly better
than most of what Bob Chapman says okay
I I feel like I came in sideways on a
conversation that was already going on I
don't know who either those people are
or what points they make so I don't know
if I would agree with them or the way
they make them I've got no basis to say
anything here how much where do we have
to beg you to watch Steven universe
Steven universe is one of the I'm sorry
backing up what Disney Animated product
products would you want to see remade
one only one remake the Black Cauldron
cuz that wasn't good and that deserve a
second shot so Steven
universe is basically like Avatar The
Last Airbender it's one of those things
that for the amount of time I'm gonna
have to sink into it there's pretty much
only two scenarios in which I get around
to it anytime soon one somebody flat out
Commission's me for the series which
would be a pretty sizable pile of cash
they'd be dropping on me which is not
unprecedented the revisit of the Harry
Potter films right now is on commission
somebody did actually fork up the dough
to Commission me to watch all 10 movies
so that's not without precedent
but either that or the patreon finally
gets the point where I can leave my day
job and you know free up some freaking
time because that's 40 hours out of my
week even then it's not like it would
immediately bounce at the top of my list
that would have to be weaved into all
the other stuff that I would be doing if
this was my full-time job ie working on
more detailed scripts you know doing
more with editing etc etc but those are
the two main scenarios in which I ever
get around to seeing either avatar
Steven universe basically any anime
series anybody ever recommends me have
you seen Dominic Nobles Harry Potter
movie 2 book comparison videos those
ones I haven't I've actually only fairly
recently got into his stuff so I haven't
done those I think partially because I
kind of want to come at the movies with
the perspective I have which is a love
but a not refreshed view of the books
because I feel like that's the way a lot
of us rewatch the movies because I don't
think a heck of a lot of us you know
refresh the book like to catch the
differences so I kind of like
maintaining the approach I've had which
is to notice the major differences that
I am aware but not catch up on little
tiny things that he tends to catalogue
which is very good at I'm not knocking
what he does I'm just saying watching
those before I finish off my my rewatch
might taint my perspective a little bit
I'm trying to avoid that
any TV streaming shows that launched
recently that you feel enticed to cover
on the channel not really see the thing
is like at this point I pretty much just
watch what I want to watch and there
hasn't been much new like new has really
done much to excite me sometimes what
will be the determining factor on that
is of a lot of people are asking me
about it but the thing is with most of
the new stuff coming out people haven't
really been pressing me on that like
I've had one person ask me about season
three of Jessica Jones which I am
finished I've had maybe two people ask
me about Watchmen I've had way more
people ask me about the boys to the
point that I have considered at least
trying the first episode of that but I
seldom found the time which that is the
perpetual issue for me it's time there
is never enough a bit um so yeah okay so
I haven't even covered why the
livestream is called what it is tonight
huh I'm off to a good start have some
more eggnog
so obviously was Chira dropping today
and I dropped my fan video for Scorpia
over on the the secondary channel over
in the break room of geeks this is kind
of where my mind's eye and a big thing
about me with cartoons is it something
I've absolutely never grown out of I
have never stopped torturing cartoons I
didn't go through a phase of having to
read reignite my passion for animation I
never lost it whatever I was still
seeing Disney movies what you know newly
really movies want well into high school
what am I my second ever girlfriend
first date we ever went to was to see
Tarzan Disney's Tarzan I was a junior in
high school we dated for a while to the
boys is actually really good especially
compared to the comic which is big just
written for the shock value see that's
why I've avoided it I'm not a big Garth
Ennis fan and also like the again if
it's
adapted properly or more specifically
updated properly it might work but it
from what I could see it appeared to be
satirizing stuff that wasn't really the
case anymore like whatever my thoughts
are about things like the boys or
whatever it was at least satirizing
comics of the time and so to adapt it
now without updating it to modern
superhero tropes would be very lazy and
I didn't see it didn't look to me like
they were doing that based off the
trailers but again I'm really saying it
would you only watch years and years if
you were patreon commissioned yeah yeah
because I've heard years and years is
great and really depressing and I'm
being very careful about how I partake
of depressing media of late I'm really
looking forward to your Harry Potter
movie rankings I shall really be
interesting it will be it and for me the
most interesting question for that is
going to be whether or not I bother to
include the two fantastic beasts movies
on the ranking at all and what I mean by
that is if they are just going to occupy
the bottom two spots then I might just
say in the intro look the bottom two are
the fantastic peace movies let's move on
to the right and actually rank the rest
because that's really dull and boring to
eat up time explaining why but I it will
be an interesting surprise to me if it
turns out that one of those gets higher
than number nine on a ranking of 10 have
you gotten a chance to watch the pilot
four has been Hotel it's an animated
series here online I actually haven't
heard of that one huh
so that no I don't I don't know that one
you mentioned once that glimmer from
Chiara is a Slytherin which I agree with
Bo seems like a Ravenclaw Scorpia is
definitely a Hufflepuff
I actually think Bo's a brainy huffily
because he's very into like keeping
everybody happy and safe and
and doing doing by everybody let you
want rape and trapped uh is like
ravenclaw in its purest form everything
is about the data everything is about
having the resources is what you're
doing right or wrong
who cares it's date ah it's no she's as
data doesn't she anyways still into the
spider-verse to announce yes I saw that
which was which was good okay you need
to watch the intro it's a collaborative
effort between freelance animators um
like remind me Meg because by the end of
this livestream I will have forgotten so
like hit me up on Twitter or email or
something poke me on that cuz I will
forget
are you a creepypastas fan not really I
kind of backdoor into them slightly cuz
I watched some channels that do like the
lore videos and whatnot and I can find
that interesting but the actual like the
whole creepypasta thing is this is not
my jam oh thanks Robert that's so
helpful it's data not data of course
they're both spelled the same so I don't
know which ones pronounce which way
that's the joke I explained it therefore
it's no longer funny is the Animatrix
somewhere on your top 10 list top 10 no
it's a really interesting piece though I
do enjoy the Animatrix um segments of it
especially there's a new version of
Christmas Carol guide Piers Andy Serkis
and Tom Hardy coming out why like and
what's the angle cuz if they're doing it
straight again there's no point what's
your favorite Disney movie would you
consider doing a sorting video on the
Disney characters like princesses or
villains I would totally be up for
sorting Disney characters um it's if I
was going to do ooh I'm sorry come right
get back to that okay Connor just
mentioned them a movie called a town
called panic it is brilliant I have seen
that that's like
my top 10 favorite animated movies I
love a town called panic
it is this bizarre ridiculous French
stop-motion thing if you like weird
animation people need to check that out
would you record act as a huff alone no
I'd have to think about that hmm have
you seen the Star Trek animated series
from 1973 only clips of it so anyway so
coming back to Disney it's really hard
for me off the top my head to come up
with like favorite is movies cuz my mind
breaks it down into eras so like in my
mind there is classic Disney era which
basically goes from a jungle book back
and and of those favorite might be
Fantasia and then there's kind of the
wilderness years that are a little iffy
and would probably go to either either
Great Mouse Detective or rescuers down
under which is really underrated I do
like both of those a lot but they get
the Disney Renaissance which kind of
Peters out by mm but yeah you know
basically the end of Disney 2d animation
but so from the Disney Renaissance
through the end of the 2d animation that
is a tough call at this point that's one
of those ones where a bit like when I
talk about Star Wars I will say that
Return of the Jedi sorry not return
Empire Strikes Back is the best Star
Wars movie but a new hope is my favorite
a bit like that with that era of Disney
Beauty and the beasts is their best but
Little Mermaid's my favorite and then
you start getting into Disney doing
their computer animated and I do I do
draw a line between Pixar and Disney I
know there's bleed over and everything
but I do make the distinction between
the studios so for Disney computer
animated it's been a really solid except
for I cut Ralph too
it's been really really solid think I
think I would say he Zootopia is the
best Moana might be my favorite but
again
tough tough call
boy I rambled on for a bit we really
don't need another version of Christmas
Carol we have the Muppets no one will
top that I mean like I'm not adverse to
like spins on it but I honestly think at
this point that's better suited for
episodes of TV show because we all know
the story so well you kind of have to do
something nuts with it but its structure
is so rigid that even the riffs on it I
think lose steam after more than an hour
so I mean I I love Christmas Carol don't
get me wrong I've seen some great
versions of it I've seen it performed on
stage I have been daeun staged versions
of it I played Marley but it's uh it's
really well-trodden ground and it's not
it's not like something like say
Sherlock where there's a ton of stories
for you to draw from it's one story with
a super rigid structure that everybody
knows there is still a lot left to do
with it it's gonna be a miniseries also
oh so they're drawing it out even longer
you played Marley oh my god me too
hey Cheers I love the version of
Christmas Carol what everyone is
terrible except Scrooge and the ghosts
coming to convince cruise the world is
awful and he could be miserable
I did like Blackadder's Christmas thing
that they didn't is it me are sequels to
cartoons animated movies more likely to
be good than live-action stuff um I
don't know if it's more likely the thing
is they really have to be undertaken
with more care because animation is it's
really hard to bungle your way through
animation I'm not gonna say it never
happens but it requires so much planning
and so much
meticulous work from so many people even
a bad animated movie is usually a
meticulously crafted animated movie
unless you're talking dirt cheap crap
you don't get a ton of incompetently
made in films I'm not like you know and
at a standard that will be released to
theaters you can get some weird ones
against a balance you get some poorly
written ones some ill-conceived ones but
usually not like just garbage from the
ground up because they there's so much
work and well that's not to undermine
you know what it takes to do the
live-action but there are segments of
live-action that people can kind of futz
their way through if your actors are
checked out they can futz their way
through their lines if your directors
just doing the you know the work for
hire they can kind of foots their way
through the through the pre-planning and
you know but you can't cut your way
through animation animation like you I
love animation since I was 5 now I'm 24
what do you think of DreamWorks Prince
of Egypt
ha much to my shame I've yet to see
Prince of Egypt which is something that
and Middleton is still on my butt about
they are they are really annoyed with me
for not having watched that yet everyone
picks on me because I can name almost
every song in every Disney movie I can
also quote Beauty and the Beast verbatim
the whole movie Tiffany you and I could
probably read dialogue back and forth
throughout the whole thing I can't sing
every part though they're not all in my
range but ya know I've got that movie
memorized too no shame in that they pick
on you heck with him fantastic mr. Fox
ParaNorman up Wally are we just naming
good ones fantastic mr. Fox I liked when
I saw it I don't know how much I'd like
it now I've kind of tired of Wes
Anderson's shtick um but ParaNorman I
love up is great Wally is 1/3 of a
masterpiece it Stephanie C really
Lindsay Ellis ha ha ha
I just bet Amazon your case about that
yeah yeah Caroline she they are really
really like I got on there on there but
every now and then for not having seen
some stuff but they will always come
back at me with Prince of Egypt
sorry comic got split oh okay don't
worry about that thoughts on what we do
in the shadows have not seen it come on
the two strings is amazing I'm like cool
on the two strings
I think the quest narrative is a little
tired for me it did it very well it's
one of those things that I have to give
it a little bit of a pass given that
it's aimed at a slightly younger
audience who might not be as bathed in
the tropes as I am um so by that measure
it's it's incredibly successful but you
know as someone who is bathed in fantasy
quest tropes that one's a little trophy
for me um I do still I get it as
gorgeously made that freaking skeleton
holy crap that thing I do love
stop-motion animation you know what I
used to walk
but I swear nobody remembers this thing
there was a stop-motion animated series
of wind and the Willows I don't know
where it aired originally I used to
watch it on the Disney Channel when I
would spend summers at my grandmother's
and I I can remember like this weird
really low voice melancholy opening song
during the credits and I'm the guy who
voiced badger had this super distinctive
voice that has always stuck with me I
love that thing I I really do like stop
animation in general it has become a an
amazing art especially with with folks
like like a really pushing what can be
done with it I'm late so it was probably
already mentioned into the spider-verse
probably my favorite animation of all
because of the different styles
incorporated it's a master's into the
spread rivers really is amazing and I am
glad they have confirmed that the sequel
is coming it was probably always gonna
have him but it's nice to have a
confirmation that was quite a
coincidence that I asked you about
Prince of Egypt my favorite animated
movie was and still his spirit I did I
liked spirit I feel like I would have
liked it better if they dropped the
voiceover though I don't think it needed
Matt Damon's narration not that he did
it badly I just don't think it needed to
be there it felt like they didn't trust
the audience to get just from the
horse's behavior and actions and I think
all of it came across with that alone I
highly recommend watching the videos of
George Rockwell Schmidt he's excellent
film discussion YouTube okay cool
Fantasia is my favorite animated film
ever it made me love animation and
classical music plus watching it Wow hi
what's anime see I am not advocating for
that though I can't imagine that was
problem excuse me that was probably
something else anomaly is a great
example stop-motion used from something
different don't know that one
have you seen Legend of Korra I still
haven't seen avatar no I haven't seen
Legends of Korra what's your favorite
Ghibli but my favorite Ghibli film is my
neighbor totoro I think I think it is
the purest distillation of the magic and
whimsy that Miyazaki does um I do need
to see more of the non Miyazaki Ghibli
films though because the I've only seen
a couple of those like I've seen a
secret World of Arrietty I've seen grave
of the fireflies but I haven't seen like
the cat returns or when Marnie was here
so I do need to see more of the studio
as a whole I've seen every Miyazaki
movie except castle of Cagliostro but I
really do need to see more of the the
rest of Ghibli because while he is kind
of the backbone of that studio he is not
their only director what's the first
Ghibli film to watch I think it depends
on what it is you like my first Ghibli
film was Princess Mononoke which despite
the fact that I live in a podunk little
town there is an art house theater and
they showed it in 99 and I freaking
loved it I understand you didn't get the
chance to watch bright burn however were
you intrigued by the concept of what if
Superman was evil I was but my immediate
suspicion is it would have made a better
half-hour short than a feature-length
film and most of the reviews that I saw
seemed to bear that out a little bit
that it didn't have the the leg the
concert didn't have the legs but again
like I didn't see like spoiler reviews
these are just general reviews cuz you
know I might still see it one day falls
on Kiki's Delivery Service it's good I
mean I don't think Miyazaki's made a bad
movie there's a couple of his that I
don't feel the need to see again like I
don't need to see Porco Rosso again I
don't need to see castle on the sky
again but the wrath that even those I
really
good my first Ghibli film was Totoro
well the thing you spoil is yourself
because that's the best one everyone
else says spirited away which is very
good I stand by Totoro which is better
dark crystal or age of resistance age of
resistance is better than the film
apologies anyone who disagrees or do you
stand on the Ice Age movies yay or nay
haha I just want to scratch solo movie
um okay they're fine is what they are
and no scratch should never solo movie
because Scrat is effectively alluding to
his character and those sorts of
characters work best in short format so
scratch is used perfectly the rest of it
is just just kind of is what it is have
you ever heard of the artist free to
call of course I've heard of Frida
Spanish heritage runs last month I was
wondering if you'd heard of her oh yeah
I've heard of her I don't know a ton
about her I'm not gonna act like I'm
educated or anything but um I'm aware of
freedom
have you seen wolf children uh-huh oh
sada film and it's really touching anime
film about a single mother raising her
werewolf children I am familiar with
wolf children that one is my daughter's
favorite anime which is not surprising
cuz she loves the wolves I like that one
a lot
that is not my favorite film from that
director though I prefer summer Wars
summer Wars right now is my favorite
anime a film
period wolf children was really good
though so is the girl who left through
time which he also directed I haven't
seen his newer stuff I need to see the
beast in the boy and he did another one
since then that I can't remember the
name of but I've really enjoyed his work
what musical do you think would work as
an animated film wicked can't watch
cocoa my gran has Alzheimer's bat yeah
that's that's legitimate
my grandfather had dementia I didn't
have Alzheimer's so we you know we as
far as how that stuff can go
we were pretty lucky because you know he
never
he didn't lose a ton of his long-term
memory but he had trouble with new
information he couldn't follow
conversations very well anymore and he
couldn't remember stuff from a month ago
he couldn't remember whether or not he'd
had breakfast but he could remember you
know his history so he didn't lose that
the way that that gets lost with
Alzheimer's but I I did still have to
see his mental state to grade which is
part of why I sort of mental degradation
is a bit of a bit of a hot button for me
oh hey Channel pups here my grandmother
has Alzheimer's and dementia as a person
that's lost a lot of family great on dad
dog Coco gives me a lot of comfort in
the idea of death that is very nice
thank you for sharing that what are your
thoughts on the upcoming MCU show what
if oh yeah I'm super excited for what if
so in case anybody doesn't know what if
is one of the Marvel series that's gonna
be on Disney plus it's gonna be animated
and it's just gonna be our spins on
stuff from the movies taken in
completely different directions with
ridiculous voice gasps I am excited for
that is your daughter into frozen is she
excited for number two my ten-year-old
is climbing the walls with excitement
waiting for that movie she is excited to
see it she kind of died she's you know
she's moved on from frozen a little bit
as like being a big thing for her but
she she enjoyed it she is she is excited
to see the next one what do you think of
the DC animated movies um they're mixed
like I have reviews for most of them up
on the channel if you hunt around
through some of the older stuff I'm
behind about a year though so I think
the last one I saw that's why something
might have been Batman ninja I can't
remember now but I am a bit behind
Dominic Noble did a video on Christmas
Carol though a unique video called Dom's
scars where he compared the various
adaptations through different
categories and awarding them I didn't
see him doing that on Christmas Carol I
did recently see his thing on the three
musketeers where he did that same thing
a long time watch her first time
commenter I just wanted to say that your
videos are great and your take on LGBT
representation they're so important
thank you for doing all of them all the
best thank you very much wait see
thank you very much randomness I
appreciate that and also Thank You Meg
for the for the super chats I should
have mentioned that as well I'm trying
to be better about acknowledging all
this stuff all of our company is one of
the most underrated Disney films ever
are you hyped for the hocus pocus sequel
and thoughts on watership down
um watership down was interesting I I
never read the book
I've seen the seventies animated film
which was that thing's a trip in and it
was it was pretty good it was dated it
was up a time I haven't seen the the
newer adaptations though as as for the
hocus pocus sequel when I actually start
filming that I'll have an opinion
because I think I mentioned this last
livestream that right now they just have
a writer assigned and there are tons of
films that get a writer signed I never
actually finish because the script
whatever gets produced has to be
greenlit then everyone s since and sign
on so don't count your chickens before
they hatch as for Oliver & Company I
would say it's somewhat under its
elements of it are really good as a
whole it's a little but it's it's a
solid piece of work why did you hate oh
oh boy oh boy here we go
why did you hate American Horror Story
coven alright one of my beefs with
American Horror Story as a show in
general is that it has a tendency to
come across as I'm not gonna claim that
they actually do this cuz I can't prove
it but it very much resembles something
that is made up as it goes which is fine
it appears to be trying to give us an
overall arching story and the problem I
have with that is they're really bad at
adhering to their own rules now how bad
this is varies from season to season
first season of American Horror Story I
thought that it was it was a minor issue
it bugged me a little bit they seem to
keep changing the rules of ghosts asylum
it didn't bother me at all because the
entire see it was still prevalent but
the entire season was based around you
know your perceptions and your brain and
white the information you were getting
not being reliable so as far as I'm
concerned they gave them license to not
have to follow the rules closely Cullen
come and not only broke its own
established rules over and over and over
again it involved magical resurrection
so early on and so often no character
death mattered
none of them and then it actually pissed
me off towards the end when they tried
to kill some characters off for real and
have it be poignant I'm like I don't
care
you have sucked out the the power of
death cuz you've undermined it
throughout this entire run of this
entire freakin show and just by the time
the characters the characters were
behaved stupidly not just selfishly they
were all selfish but like stupid even
for what their goals were they were
acting stupid I'd uh I really didn't
like that season at all like the only
thing Kathy Bates was great but that's a
performance thing the the character was
it was fine it was Kathy Bates she can
elevate anything I am pleased you want
to sort the Disney characters but there
are so many you're gonna have to split
into several categories princes
princesses of villains okay so what I
probably have to do I probably have to
split it as heroes villains and
sidekicks and I might have to do hero
and villain sidekicks as separate
categories
I don't know we'll see if you want a
better come and watch a mark borscht
guards short film coven okay I've seen
the animated Titanic movie in it C
equals no I only know them by reputation
because I saw the nostalgia critic
reviews of them back before everything
went down at channel ah stop watching
that channel but I so I know them
through that I've never seen them myself
that I'm I'm not a huh I'm not a
connoisseur of a bad media in general
and I'm really not a connoisseur of bad
animation I love animation so much that
it pains me to see it done badly or
haphazardly so no I don't see that
happening can heroes be sexy of course
they can that's that's an odd question I
think broadly speaking it's eat
broadly speaking heroes are the most
likely to be bland of any character in a
story because you kind of have the
freedom to have a lot more fun with
supporting characters of villains good
news after 5 Monson's my house fire my
flirting cat hath returneth that is
wonderful to hear donna i'm so happy you
have your flirting cat back I'm not even
I'm not even joking I mean I'm rolling
with the joke you made but I'm
legitimately happy to hear that you
prefer Jimmy John's or subway I've never
even had a Jimmy John's they do not
exist stop where I am favorite
scooby-doo movie I'm not sure I've seen
any of the movies I don't have unless
you want to count scooby-doo and Batman
braving the bold I've seen that one it
was pretty good what is the weirdest and
or scariest episode of a cartoon you've
ever seen I'll explain Hine in another
message post
I don't know I don't recall ever being
scared by an episode of an animated TV
show I mean my brain is kind of combing
through the Real Ghostbusters which is
one of my favorite cartoons of all time
still and the best episodes of that
series are still good not the entire
series is still good but like the best
episodes of that show are still good and
that stuff was weird and potentially
scary but that was also why I liked it
in the first place
I think we should have gotten Oh Dania
lost it I think we should have gotten
another avatar series I want to know
what happened to Korra when she got
older what she did she could be a great
mentor I'll take your word for that I
haven't seen it what do you think of
tightness season one is OK season two
has really stepped it up I haven't
gotten to season two the thing is you
need to remember I watched season one
because I was commissioned to do it I'm
not I don't have the subscription
service that it's on so unless I have
reason to get it again I don't know what
when or if I'm gonna get to that or to
Swamp Thing for that matter is there a
cartoon animation that was so good story
wise that you loved it despite it's bad
animation no no I've never seen
something that had a really good story
but subpar animation I've seen things
that had mediocre animation and a decent
story but that's not quite what you're
asking me and I can't think of any
instances of that of what you're
describing I mistakenly thought my
cousin said they were transitioning
turns out she was referring to what the
gender of her new baby was going to be I
feel really really stupid now
hahahahahaah honest mistake we all make
them uh will you ever rank the doctors
in attractiveness I mean I mean like I
don't know if I'll ever do an official
ranking below bullet but let's just be
honest right now
Peter Capaldi he can get it he can get
it okay
you have to watch avatar legend of and
Korra their amazing show you love it I'm
sure I will love it I'm sure when I
finally get around to do it I will love
it I'm sure when I finally get around to
it I will love Stevie universe I'm sure
when I finally get around to it I will
love gravity falls I don't have time I
work 40 hours a week in office strange
Hill High had a beautiful animation
style a lot of abstract stop-motion
thing it's you kick it show haven't
heard of that one Matt Smith is the most
attractive to me personally then Jodie
Whittaker um I mean the thing is I'm at
a point in my life where attractiveness
is just as much about the projection of
what someone puts out there as it is
about their look so you know I can look
at someone like the third doctor and I'm
not entirely sure that I go for John
Pertwee generally physically but it's so
dang dashing like that counts for a lot
may I shell a web animate oh sure go
nuts
the doctor liked to be his jelly baby oh
oh dear
it wasn't about looks but totally agree
cool that works I have a thing for the
grumpy with a gooey Center there is
there is something endearing about that
I went to a convention last weekend and
got autographs and photos with MH a
voice actors ma che my hero academia I'm
learning some of the acronyms
I usually don't know them to be honest
to be honest when you we do me ask me
you got those weapons on your sword rag
did you play two roles or were you were
ninja I I took karate for 10 years when
I was a kid I don't know how to use any
of this though I've got let go you know
1 2 3 4 I've got four swords up there
there's another over there I've got an
axe 105 swords Cutlass we've got the Sai
I don't know how to properly use any of
this stuff so I do have to pop over to
the discord if folks will pardon me so
this is my reminder to everyone that the
Council of geeks discord server is a
patreon exclusive perk at $2 a month you
feel like helping me out that will be
freaking amazing and you can and you'll
get that perk as a result
anyways let's see what have I got in
here who's your favorite Animaniacs
character up at this point it's Yakko
back when it originally aired I went
wacko cuz I was more into the more sort
of juvenile humor that he tended to to
provide you know the belching and and
everything else what city was doing the
anime in general meaning not just
Japanese and cartoons
that really depends on who you ask I
mean for me I distinguish anime as a
visual style whether or not it comes
from Japan and then I basically lump mmm
any other 2d kind of animation under
cartoons I will distinguish 3d animation
I will distinguish stop-motion animation
because there is enough of a different
process and aesthetic to those things
versus what I tend to think of as
cartoons I mean once engrained in my
head is the is the very outdated and no
longer in existence Saturday morning
cartoons that's my personal frame of
reference boy those learn a thing
anymore oh boy uh would you be
interested in seeing a live-action
static shock ah my horrible geek for
admitting to never haven't gotten around
to seeing the original static shock so I
don't know if you're not familiar would
you like a copy to watch I wouldn't say
no what in your opinion makes something
better fit for being adapted into an
animated format other than live-action I
think a lot of it honestly has to do
with whether or not the story benefits
from realism because what live-action
brings inherently that animation even
really your realistic style animation
does not bring because with animation
get uncanny valley thing is realism it
feels like it's happening in some
approximation of the real world so if a
story doesn't benefit from realism then
that for me is the biggest driving
reason to do it animated so something
like water shutdown would be a really
good example there's no real benefit to
doing that realistically it should be
stylized in a way that you would never
get from live-action no branding you
couldn't actually get training the
rabbits to do all this stuff but that
that's kind of my point and also I'm
kind of of the mind that it
I would I wish that more adult audience
aimed fantasy or just older age aimed
fantasy was done in animation because a
movie that blew my mind when I was 13
was Ralph Bakshi's wizards and I would
love to see more stuff like that stuff
that is animated because I think fantasy
lends itself to animations so well but
in Western culture at least we have so
hard and grained the animation is for
kids thing and and on the few instances
where you get Western animation that
isn't for kids they push so hard we want
not for kids they jack up the violence
and the sexual content to a degree that
usually isn't necessary fire and ice
but I I really wish that fantasy as a
genre existed more in the realm of
animation because I think things like
The Last Unicorn is one of the greatest
fantasy movies ever made but people
separated out from conversations about
things like Lord of the Rings and things
like that simply because it's animated
that's stupid as far as I'm concerned
sorry I'm just gonna try and catch up on
the rest of the discord which old
cartoon 80s or earlier do you like or
love and no one else seems to remember
um can name a cartoon
I can't however name you a made-for-tv
special that nobody seemed to remember
up until the Nostalgia Critic did a
review of it and that was Care Bears in
Wonderland I did genuinely really like
that what type of animation style and
tech is your current favorite for
cartoons hand-drawn CGI 2d 3d etc I mean
my default always gonna be 2d animation
that's where my heart is
but I love animation in general how do
you feel about the end of gargoyles
who's all right I mean
he's a one of Garko goals for me is wow
golden sweet spot the second season was
our end by ending I'm assuming you mean
the end of season 2 because it was like
the Goliath chronicles but the creator
has disowned that so I don't count that
what's your opinion on the 2018 version
of the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
haven't seen it I like traditional
animation style more than using a ton of
computer-generated animation how do you
feel yeah yeah that's basically where I
am and popping on back to the stream I'm
off the discord there we go uh I loved
wizards my favorite of his was American
pop the thing is I actually haven't seen
a ton of boxey's stuff because other
than wizards I haven't liked a lot of it
I really do love wizards though that
said I haven't gone back and revisited
it excuse me
having gone back and revisited it as an
adult there's some of it that really
drags like some of the rotoscope stuff
like oh boy it drags on I really do
enjoy that movie though I really want
them to animate Daleks masterplan is my
favorite Hartnell story but it's full
parts long not as bad as it sounds so
it's much more difficult Amy I mean
they'll probably get to it eventually I
just wish that they were putting more
money behind the animation budgets on
those things I'm glad we have them
because more people are experiencing
these stories now as these lost episodes
of Doctor Who get animated but once
they're done once I fear that they won't
be redone again better and I kind of
wish that they were just doing better
with them
what animation or anime gets you right
in the fields I saw the one recently
about a girl who came back from heaven
to her friends who was with her when she
died and the end I haven't I don't know
what one you're referring to there but
like okay mallanna gets me in the fields
up gets me in the fields or I can route
it's me in the fields summer Wars gets
me in the fields there's quite a few I'm
twenty-one year old college students who
loves Hello Kitty
her franchise is turning 45 this year
I'm younger than Hello Kitty haha I
didn't know you were that young Connor
have you ever seen Batman Beyond ah
I've only seen a couple of episodes of
the show but Batman Beyond return of the
Joker is one of the best I animated
Batman films I will put it up right next
to mask of the phantasm they are neck
and neck in my book
normally I saved the downing the rest of
that until the end of stream but you
know it was eggnog it was getting warm
eggnog with nothing else added you can
trust me have you seen Leo on stitch I
have it's really overrated by a lot of
people my age and somewhat younger those
stitches characters are great but that
story I don't really care too much for
our youcan't American Horror Story
probably not I'm several seasons behind
returned the Joker mask of the phantasm
under the Red Hood or my favorite
animated films I think I know the red
hoods really overrated
oh sorry favorite DC animated movie um
are you a Trekkie or Star Wars fan I I
am a Star Wars fan I like Star Trek I'm
not into it enough to I think get away
we calling myself a Trekkie a step
favorite DC Animated um I mean - talvik
favorite would be return of the Joker
which is the Batman Beyond one but best
hmm that is like from from a
construction structure execution
standpoint probably mask of the phantasm
is the best
what about return to the caped crusaders
that's a lot of fun I love the heck out
of that
have you seen my recommendation I might
have I I don't I don't know I'm not
backtracking through the through the
chat tonight I
it's a massive headache for me to do
that love love love the Emperor's New
Groove why do you even have that lever
I'd like the Emperor's New Groove a lot
it's weird to me because like other
Disney fans will crap on it is like it's
not dizzy sad like well no it's not it's
experimental is more Looney Tunes asked
in its execution and humor but it
doesn't really well yes it's a typical
of Disney but it's well executed so
what's your problem second half of a
two-part I know you love Treasure Planet
what about Atlantis
I don't like Atlantis all that much do
you watch her have you heard of critical
role heard of it haven't watched it like
the thing with Atlantis I like the style
a lot the visual style but it couldn't
seem to settle on a tone like the tone
of the film is pretty serious the tone
of a lot of the characters is very silly
eh I don't it's not well balanced with
its elements I don't think I'm mod to
Star Trek YouTube channels on a Star
Trek discord you should do a video on
the state of fandoms at the moment I
don't know enough about what's going on
in the Star Trek fandom to do a video
addressing that and I I will talk about
fandoms in the broad-strokes
I try not to talk too specifically about
certain fandoms just because I don't
like throwing stones like it'll come up
like when I talk about Star Wars I want
to talk about Doctor Who because I kind
of already know those fandoms but I
tried like to dedicate video
specifically to that cuz it's some fun
for me to do that
I love the animated as act rocker
stories okay cool
wait what's wrong with the Star Trek
fandom what have I missed
I don't know like that's my point I know
I know discovery appears to continue to
remain divisive but like I don't know
don't ask me please how far into
American Horror Story are you say we
talk about coven but Madison was awesome
she's literally my spirit animal
well I'm mmm all right I was keep my
thoughts on that to myself like I've
seen the first five seasons of American
Horror Story only really enjoyed to kind
of liked one didn't like two of them
that's not a great batting average
I started Roanoke it had an interesting
conceit but then the same problem that I
have with everything else I don't have
the time like you guys you guys got to
spread the word you got to get more
people on my patreon you got to get me
out of that job huh if you want me to
have the time to see this stuff which
Winx hunting and free phonics music
based superpowers and goth rock villains
are my old non anime picks I've heard of
Winx and I have not heard of any of the
rest of those so good job going um going
at least by my metric obscure maybe
other people know this stuff have you
seen enough of a certain shear on new
characters to get an impression of them
um I mean I'm only two episodes in I
know I know people are gonna ask me
about my opinion on the non-binary
nature of that character and I don't
really have one because the character
seems to weigh more to be a ascends up
of you know sort of the generic oh I
kids into character exaggerated actor
tropes more than it is addressing gender
at least as far as I've gotten into the
thing and that's not at stereotype or a
trope I much care for maybe cuz it hits
too close to home because I am a
acting performance type so but two
episodes in my character hasn't really
endeared themselves to me that much
Star Trek fandom is yeah Discovery's
mostly hated they shut politics down
okay I'm stepping away from it cuz I
understand there's an argument going on
within the fandom I haven't seen
discovery I don't have an opinion on it
I don't know enough about the infighting
to have an opinion on that I'm walking
away Simpsons are Futurama depends on
whether you're gonna force me to
incorporate the entirety of The Simpsons
or can I if I could pick and choose the
same number of Simpsons seasons as there
were Futurama seasons which is what
eight nine ish if you count the movies
as a season then probably Simpsons but
if you're gonna force me to go
everything and everything then I'd
probably say Futurama and in addition to
the Fifty Shades review did you know Stu
bag full has review barny the dinosaur
movie in a very sarcastic manner yes I
have seen that is there any non animated
entity you think should get an animated
treatment Doctor Who musicals red dwarf
etc etc etc um hmm
currently Nanak animated friends that
would be better served in animation I
don't have one off the top of my head I
feel like I should but I'm just I'm just
kind of drawing a blank on that sorry
the actress Lisa Stokke who plays the
Norwegian man's dead wife in the Doctor
Who a hue is the voice of Elsa for the
Norwegian dub of frozen okay sure
who's the butter punk singer Debra hey
Debbie Harry a blonde or Joan Jett of
the Black Arts if you're going for the
punk angle I'm gonna give it to Jett
sorry I missed a fair few of these
streams just restarting University no
worries I'm wrapping it up soon you got
about two minutes left and then I'm
getting back to more she rock what I'm
doing it when it comes to heroes I want
to see more non American heroes Irish
folklore could give rise to an insane
pirate here
oh good Irish folklore movies um Secret
of Kells and song of the sea both very
good
I prefer Secret of Kells personally
excellent movies I tangent it off your
point but if you had creative control of
Doctor Who what would you do with it I
don't know because on paper series 11
did a lot of the things that I would
have done get rid of the overarching
story for the season not have any
recurring villains for one full series
do more standalone stories a lot of my
broad-stroke ideas chip Dahl did and
then like like wish you wishing on a
monkey's paw they somehow still resulted
in something that I didn't really like
so there you go with six kids I'm stuck
watching a lot of recent animated movies
and TV but I really try to get my kids
to watch 80s 90s and early 2000 stuff
because I'm knowingly biased to that
time period I know what you mean Tiffany
hi my kid was it into briefly a fair
amount of the stuff I liked like she she
watched episodes from my box sets of
Batman the Animated Series and
Buster's at this point though she's
eight and she's kind of found her own
stuff funnily enough though the main
thing she's in do right now is Pokemon
she's watching the 90s cartoon which my
era also not my fandom so there you go
but she is really good here - Pokemon
seriously you folks I'm telling you
alright
instorage Star Trek discovery divisive
discussion was snatched up by
politically motivated channels good ol
Internet ok so basically the same thing
that happened to Doctor Who fun what
what would you think of a Doctor Who
musical episode I really rather they
didn't I think I think just the time for
that is fast
did you know Mark Gatiss has played the
master in an alternate Big Finish story
under an anagram of his name I did hear
that I haven't heard that one though and
I am going to wrap this up whoa hang on
what is the opinion of Madison from
coven okay so I'm sorry randomness but
my memory of coven is so vague at this
point I don't remember which one Madison
was I'm assuming that was Emily
Roberts's character she played it well
for the kind of character it was I don't
know what you think you're gonna get
from me do you think the details on what
do you think of the details on the
Batman Matt Reeves movie Andy Serkis
starring is out Fredette cetera when was
that confirmed I didn't hear that when
did that happen if you could remake
Harry Potter in any medium TV full see
this is enough television per book you
get all the stuff in the classroom that
got cut out plus more time in the
classrooms then even the books did all
right you guys suck suck me in like I
said I was gonna end I'm ending I got I
got a stop I got a
stop so ah thanks are you gonna review
Watchmen probably not I don't have HBO
anymore so alright so let's let's wrap
it up there thank you everybody for
tuning in I hope you had a good week
hope we had fun with this I always enjoy
doing this thank you everybody who tuned
in thank you to the folks who did super
chat thank you for the folks over in the
discord I know I tend to [ __ ] about the
fact that I don't have time but honest
to god if I could ever get things up to
the point where I could afford to leave
my job that would be amazing but even if
I can't the just the back-and-forth that
we get and the correspondence and
getting to talk with you folks once a
week I love doing that I love hearing
from you and you are beautiful
you're valid you are loved you are the
counsel
I'm just running the meetings have a
good night everybody